[Music]
Cur Merry Christmas it's been a busy
Year I hope you get a chance to have a
good break over the Christmas holidays
where you'll get a chance to recharge
your
batteries as we come into Christmas I
hope you get time to spend time with
your family and those you care about the
do Spirit a thought for those who may be
alone a smile
and that random act of kindness may be
enough to brighten someone's
day like to take this opportunity to
thank our emergency services for all
that they do to keep us safe and
protected through this
time on behalf of the council and our
community can I wish you all a very
merry Christmas and I hope you get a
great chance to enjoy the New Year look
forward to connecting with you again in
2024 Merry Christmas and can use
[Music]
it